so how does it feel attending this
Premiere as a director not just an actor
is it different for you I mean uh maybe
a little bit I just know I got to
introduce the movie so I think other
than that I'm just kind of like it's
kind of business as usual that's the big
word I think so I think for right now
it's kind of business as usual right now
just talking with you guys you know
talking about the movie talking about
you know my wonderful actors it's
awesome I saw all the
everybody's here tonight
yeah I am I'm we think out here tonight
you know and it feels good you know um
Hometown crowd you know I got my family
here they're watching the movie for the
first time so it's really special
tonight
whatever you do just do not start
wrestling with me in here right now okay
not tonight not now but he's uh he's
awesome
okay let's talk about something else
awesome let's do it that Calvin Klein
ass first start when you saw
[Music]
he can't be the only one out here yeah
he can't be the only one out here with
no clothes I'm just saying seriously
when you saw it were you like oh damn
which one this one no yeah oh yeah yeah
it was it was it was uh I was like my
mama gonna have to see this let me call
her I'm sorry it's out here got my
business all out in the streets
literally your business was out in the
street I don't think anybody mined it
but your business was out in the street
now you know you got to be proud of them
though you worked hard for that yeah I
mean everything I mean this is like a
moment you know just have everything
kind of coming together at one time it
feels great you know and be able to
share that moment with you know my other
actors was having a moment of their own
as well they just feels special it feels
like everything's happening the right
time quickly we got a news earlier that
I am Legend is going forward what do you
expect from this collaboration with you
and will for this movie I think great
things you know I think honestly we're
in the process developing the story
figuring out the script I know there's a
long road so we actually start to you
know step on and get on set and actually
start filming but I think that you know
it's I'm excited about it you know what
I'm saying I'm excited about building it
so I'm looking forward to it and finally
you came back for black panther we were
so so happy about that but now you're
going to take on the DC role of black
Superman
who's that I said that you said that I
didn't say that I don't even know about
no rumors about that one okay okay wow
[Music]
foreign